just to delve more into flaw flaw is the
direct opposite of strength yeah
so on my nutshell technique form I pose
as two opposites you know what is the
character central flaw and then what is
the strength that in the end in a comedy
they either learn the opposite of or in
a tragedy was the strength that they
fail to learn the opposite of one thing
I noticed sometimes if it's hard time so
people have multiple flaws you know we
don't have just one flaw but typically
they only learn one thing so sometimes
when I'm working with a writer and they
have a hard time identifying you know
what is the flaw is that insecurity is
that lack of self-worth is it you know a
couple we might bad about a couple
things sometimes I try not to pick one
necessarily until we look at the third
act and see if it's comedy and see well
what is the what is the message what is
this the thing that they are changing to
because all three of those flaws we
mentioned may be the case but they will
probably only discover that one opposite
strength because we typically in a at
least in a story are only gonna discover
one thing so what in the third act we
see that they're finally discovered the
sense of self-worth
so we'll identify that is the nutshell
flaw its opposite that they had a lack
of self-worth even though they may also
be insecure and have some other flaws
but you want to ultimately when you're
using the nutshell technique form you
want to phrase those as two direct
opposites and there should be direct
opposites so if we were gonna you know
call in Tootsie we're gonna say that he
is his flaw is a misogynist then we'd
have to identify what is the direct
opposite of that would be not even sure
what that would be someone who who has I
would end up saying something like
respect for women so it's a need or
opposite then to say the flaw is lack of
respect of women instead of misogynist
so that they're clean opposites so I
kind of a saw will work with the writer
sometime to massage them so that we have
nice clear opposites so they shouldn't
just be vaguely ones positive ones
negative they should they should be
direct opposites whatever they are and
in the case of the tragedy I think it's
important to we also identify the
strength that they failed to learn so
the idea in a tragedy is that the reason
why they have the tragic ending is
because they failed to change from the
flaw so we use on the same form we
identify what would that strength be
it's just that we can imagine in our
minds I had they gained had Joe Gillis
in Sunset Boulevard discovered hope
instead of being cynical then we can
kind of imagine okay now I see how that
would have been a happy ending right how
do you discovered that then he would
have accepted when the love interest
says I haven't heard any of this let's
just go he would have said you're right
let's just go so it's important to
identify go ahead and put into words
what is that strength even though the
point is in a tragedy they don't achieve
that strength they stay flawed but what
would have changed their destiny had
they discovered it because we should
feel that we should feel that in that
what makes a satisfying tragedy
tragedies are tricky but I think they
can be very satisfying when we have to
feel like oh oh if he'd done that oh I
can feel I can just almost taste it that
he could have actually discovered that
opposite strength that I can imagine
that happy ending that would have
happened on a subconscious level we feel
that with with Sunset Boulevard that's
why it works when he makes that choice
to rub Betty's face in it we're like oh
why are you doing that why are you doing
that you had your chance right that's
what we're feeling we're feeling that
hope that hope he should have had but
that flaw just took them over sure but
without that it doesn't feel satisfying
it just feels forced if we don't if
we're not conscious about it if
someone's just doing tragic things
without reason I'm just wondering about
films that have multiple flawed
characters I'm thinking of like The
Breakfast Club and I guess you could say
if I remember correctly Judd Nelson is
like the protagonist I'm trying to
remember because there's so many voices
in that but how is that dealing with
multiple flawed characters if they're
flawed from the beginning we know
they're flawed they're in detention how
does that work well I would say first of
all if a movie successfully tells a
story
only one of them is technically the
protagonist and let me mention that's a
tool for the writer audience doesn't
need to know that audience can think
it's a you know it's an ensemble picture
and that there isn't a protagonist
that's fine let them think it's an
ensemble picture it's for you the writer
to structure the story to know yeah but
secretly Judd Nelson's the protagonist
right and and this is good news for you
as a writer because only one character
has to truly have a nutshell that a
hundred percent works so the other
characters may and generally we're going
to want to see that you know if it is
story that it's a structure structurally
an Aristotelian comedy we're gonna want
to see most of the characters make a
change or a flaw to strength but only
one of them has to have all the nutshell
elements work it's just gonna make your
life easier so the other characters may
have interesting you know the flawed
strength that's their character art but
structurally you can know
well secretly just this one character is
truly the protagonist and that's the
backbone and then it's gonna be easier
to let all the other pieces fall into
place and again it's for the brightest
benefit audience doesn't audience can
think it's an ensemble picture audience
can tell their friends oh no there's no
protagonist it's an ensemble picture
that's fine let them think that
you